you awake - aloud thump as the waves
crash against the hull of the ship the
holes echo instructions from your
captain there's a storm coming boys you
jump to your feet and race to the top
deck some of the crew are scurrying
frantically to secure the hull but there
are so many of them missing as you begin
to question where they have gone you
hear shouts of Man Overboard
and turn to see your peers leaning over
the edge of the ship
fixated on the ocean they begin to jump
one by one to almost certain death as
you approach you start to hear a song
the song is familiar but at the same
time you've never heard anything like
this the song has a soothing effect and
you are captivated by the melody you
begin to forget your surroundings you no
longer hear the screams of your crew or
the waves that bombard the ship you are
no longer in a storm you glanced into
the distance and see the outline of a
woman laying on a bed of rocks it
appears that she's gesturing for you to
join her but as you look down you see
the lifeless bodies of your crew being
carried away by the waves unable to stop
yourself you begin to climb overboard
knowing that it would mean certain death
if only you could warn the rest of the
crew of the song if only you could stop
them share in your fate but at this
point you are nothing more than a
passenger in your own body as you plunge
into the cold dark abyss you finally
realize that the sirens song is the last
you will ever hear
in Greek mythology the sirens or
beautiful creatures but they were also
extremely dangerous
Lauren many sailors to their doom with
their enchanting voices the sirens are
mentioned by numerous authors and they
are said to be the daughters of four
seas one of the primordial sea gods and
their mother one of the nine Muses which
could be why they are graced of such
elegant voices the amount of sirens is
something that varies depending on the
author or the story and most tend to
disagree in some stories there are two
or three and in others there are many
more according to some of the older
stories the sirens accompanied
Persephone the daughter of Zeus and
demet are shortly after Persephone's
abduction by Hades the sirens were given
their wings in some accounts the sirens
requested these wings in order to aid
them in their search for their mistress
and in others the wings were a form of
punishment from Demeter because the
sirens were unable to prevent the
abduction of Persephone their song was
an enchanting but sad melody eternally
calling for the return of Persephone
it's because of this myth that the
sirens are depicted as birds with the
heads of women almost harpy like the
earliest depictions of the sirens
described them as nymph like creatures
and they could be seen living amongst
the muses there are stories where the
sirens would compete against the muses
to see who had the best voice when the
sirens lost as punishment they would
have their feathers plucked from them
one of the most famous stories regarding
the sirens can be found in Homer's
Odyssey in this story the sirens are
said to live on an island near Scylla
the hero Odysseus has warned how
dangerous the sirens are and he comes up
with a plan to cross the island safely
in order to stop his men being seduced
by the sirens
he had them blocked their ears using wax
because of his curiosity
Odysseus did not block his own ears as
he wanted to hear the song of the siren
instead he tied himself to the mast of
his ship and as they sailed past the
island his men were unaffected by the
sirens singing Odysseus however
struggled to resist but his men stood
firm and ignored his demands to untie
him Odysseus would become one of the
only men to have heard the song of the
siren and lived to tell the tale
in some versions of the story there was
a prophecy that stated if anyone heard
the song of the siren and lived the
sirens would die there is an alternative
ending to this tale where the sirens
would take revenge on Odysseus by taking
his son another popular myth involves
jason and the argonauts who had to sail
past the island of the sirens
rather than blocked their ears the
Argonauts had the famed musician Orpheus
accompany them when the sirens began to
sing in an attempt to seduce the
Argonauts Orpheus began to play his harp
and the music overpowered the voice of
the sirens one of the Argonauts did fall
victims that are some of the siren and
he jumped out of the ships women towards
them but he was lucky enough to have
been saved by the goddess Aphrodite
the sirens are definitely interesting
creatures in Greek mythology their exact
origins may be a little bit hazy as
there are several figures that could be
considered their mother and father over
the years their appearance has
definitely changed
going from nymph to almost harpy like in
Greek mythology if we take a look
outside Greek mythology the sirens are
now depicted as almost mermaid like
creatures who live in the sea they serve
as a warning that looks can be deceiving
they are both beautiful and deadly
[Music]
[Music]